you've probably heard of the nfl's
rooney rule
but is it really working in 2021 the nfl
policy was named after the league's
former diversity committee chairperson
the late dan rooney it was instituted in
2003
then expanded in 2009 requiring teams
with vacancies for head coaches
general managers and similar front
office roles to interview at least one
diverse candidate for those jobs in 2003
there had only been six black head
coaches in the modern era
the rule appeared to show promise in
2006
and 2007 with six black head coaches in
permanent positions
in 2020 the rule was updated requiring
teams to interview
at least two external minority
candidates for head coaching openings
and at least
one minority candidate for any
coordinator job
as well as one external minority
candidate for senior football operations
and general manager jobs the truth is
only four head coaches of color and four
general managers of color
hold positions in the nfl and two of the
32 nfl
teams have owners who are not white the
numbers are glaring and the interviewing
process has shown to be more of a chore
than honest due diligence this year's
super bowl featured a handful of
potential future head coaches of color
chief's offensive expert eric the enemy
has been discussed as a potential head
coach for the last few seasons
and while tom brady and bruce arians
have received
much of the credit for the buccaneer's
success this season
all of the team's major coordinators are
black men offensive coordinator byron
leftwich
assistant head coach harold goodwin
defensive coordinator todd bowles
and special teams coordinator keith
armstrong
the enemy has been passed over by
multiple teams
bulls who took interviews with the
eagles and
falcons had a scheduled interview with
the detroit lions
before they canceled and hired dan
campbell while leftwich
didn't even receive an interview there
is no clear accountability from the
league regarding the rooney rule
the rule hasn't panned out which doesn't
mean it's a failure
it was just a starting point the nfl can
create
all the incentives to jump start
high-level hiring of people of color and
women but in the end
the future of the rule and its evolution
is directly tied to the owners
in modern nfl history only 23 head
coaches of color have been hired
in the nfl and the responsibility to fix
that lies at the owner's feet